We need to figure out what
99.061 divided by 100 is.
So we are figuring out what
99.061 divided by 100.
So in this situation,
our divisor is
already a whole number.
So we don't have to do any of
that multiplying by 10 or 100
to move the decimal
over to the right.
It's already a whole number,
so we're ready to divide.
But the first thing we want to
do in this, just to make sure
we don't make any mistakes, is
make sure we put the decimal
in the right place.
So the decimal is going to
sit right over here.
This is where it was sitting
before, so this is where it
will sit in our quotient.
And now we are ready
to divide.
So the first thing we want
to say is, well,
does 100 go into 9?
Well, no it doesn't.
So does 100 go into 99?
No, it doesn't.
And if we want, we could put a
zero here, or we could just
keep going.
We'll add the 0 at the end.
So 100 doesn't go into 9,
it doesn't go into 99.
Does 100 go into 990?
Sure!
It'll go nine times.
It goes into 990 nine times.
So that's why we put the 9 above
the 0, because we had to
get all the way to the 0 for the
100 to be divisible into
the number.
100 goes into 990 nine times.
9 times 100 is 900.
And then we can subtract.
So 990 minus 900 is 90.
We can do that in our heads.
You can say, 0 minus 0 is 0.
9 minus 0 is 9.
These guys cancel out.
Now we can bring down this 6.
100 goes into 906 nine times.
9 times 100 is 900, and
then we can subtract.
906 minus 900 is
going to be 6.
And then we bring down the 1.
100 goes into 61.
It doesn't!
It goes into it zero times.
0 times 100 is 0.
And then when you subtract, you
have a remainder of 61.
Now, you might be tempted to
say, OK, it goes into it--
well, we could always put a
leading 0 here-- 0.990 times
with a remainder of 61.
First of all, that's
not right.
The remainder isn't 61, because
we're now to the right
of the decimal point.
But in general, whenever you're
dividing to decimals,
you want to keep dividing.
You don't want to
have remainder.
And the best way to keep
dividing is to remember that
this has as many trailing zeroes
on it as you want.
They're not really changing
the number.
So we can throw a bunch of
zeroes to the right of here,
as many as we need.
So let's throw a
zero right now.
Bring it down.
100 goes into 610 six times.
6 times 100 is 600.
And then we subtract.
610 minus 600 is 10.
We don't want to have a
remainder, so we keep going.
So let's throw another zero
here and bring it down.
So we have another zero there.
100 goes into 100 exactly
one time.
1 times 100 is 100.
And then now when you
subtract, we have no
remainder, and we
are satisfied.
And we're done.
And sometimes you're going to
see that you're going to have
to keep doing it, and you're
going to start having repeated
numbers up here, and strange
things up here.
And there's other ways
we'll deal with that.
But in this circumstance, you
just want to keep going.
You want to keep going until
you have no remainder.
So our final answer is
99.061 divided by
100 is equal to 0.99061.
And I just put a leading
zero here.
Sometimes it makes it easier
to read, and you make sure
people understand that there's
a decimal there.
It just makes it less
prone to errors.
And we are done.
And just to make the point,
this actually makes sense.
99 is a little bit less than
100, so 99 divided by 100 is
going to be a little
bit less than 1.
And this number is a little